each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
with that I'm going to introduce our
speaker Ayman is one of the program
managers / working in the engineering
team on Windows Phone and he's going to
give a talk on basically getting started
with phone development specifically
using silverlight so without further ado
here's Ayman can you ever run in the
back here me or is this can you guys
hear me all right cool awesome day all
right let me just switch it over to the
other okay oh definitely not good all
right so basically has been said I'm
actually from the server light for
Windows Phone team today I'll just go
over kind of some of the basics of what
is really silverlight and how how can
you can use it for the phone and
basically have to get started like
writing cool apps so basically it's just
the key takeaways here just to how to
create the Silverlight application how
to leverage your own creativity and
basically what are the tools to actually
make it happen so basically the cool
part about server light is it gives the
ability for folks to collaborate
together so if you're a good programmer
you can actually use it in collaboration
with a great designer so the idea is it
actually created this unique interface
between the two that folks can actually
collaborate together and do a lot of
cool powerful stuff now the other
advantage of server light is in terms of
you also have a lot of things out of the
box that you can actually use and get
you going quicker and faster and so
basically also the other Silverlight
capabilities is you also have the other
kind of capacities that you can use it
so whether it's actually an example
based and I'll go into details of what
is that and also in terms of input you
can it's actually geared towards a
keyboard mouse touch so on and also in
terms of media where that's its kind of
core strength as well as you have other
kind of connectivity with other data
and other kind of networking data
services model that you can connect to
as well so basically the idea is the
elements counter for Windows Phone
development it's not just like one area
it's actually a collaboration of all all
folks together so basically you have the
runtime you have for the phone you have
silverlight as well as XNA in order for
you to be able to create your app so
basically both have access to the phone
in terms of sensors what it's kind of
the media stack as well as the manager
run time frame before it now the cool
part about silver lacked in XNA is they
there are the same model that you had on
the desktop so you can actually leverage
and you we use your code as much as
possible so basically we were already
you know so if you have an XNA game
that's actually on the Xbox you can
actually now pour it over to the windows
phone which is really easy to do as well
as if you have like a windows server
light desktop app that you want to pour
it over to the phone you can do that as
well easily now also in terms of the
tools you have in terms of the visual
studio and microsoft visual blend where
you have you know the phone emulator you
have a abundance of samples of course
with microsoft this you know developers
are old number one developer developer
developer know Steve online so and also
in terms of let you eat so you also have
an abundance of tools basically be
visual blend and as well as visual
studio for windows phone now also you
have that connected with the cert with
the cloud as well where you have Windows
Azure you also have Xbox Live services
for certain partners and you have we
have the ability to actually connect you
to the cloud easily and also the other
part of it is the services for the
windows phone services where if you're
an app developer you need to register
and basically it monitors all your
revenue it manages all your kind of okay
what is the money coming in for you and
what are the number of installs who who
installed your apps so on and so forth
so it's actually giving you a lot of
cool services on top of that so
basically what is kind of silverlight 4
phone um just kind of a quick question
how many like how many people here know
about silverlight okay cool so sounds
and so that okay so so what so most of
the folks here are interns and like from
college yes yeah all right okay that's
it yes all right cool that sounds good
so so basically yes so for server life
for phone is basically just currently
right now on windows phone 7 it was
several i3 plus those modifications
right now in manga we have actually
silverlight 4 so all the cool kind of
data modeler sale we actually also
ported from angle as well so basically
what is different is just simply we did
a lot of performance suiting also in
terms of the input integration with the
device and as well as we have
integration with the camera and the
media stacks on the phone as well also
the the application model is more tuned
towards the phone so it's not this
different kind of like on a browser so
we tweaked that to actually match more
on the phone itself and basically we
moved a lot of the constraints that you
had in the browser so for example if you
want to access camera you on the browser
you have to actually give permission or
something like that on the phone you
don't have that restriction so some of
those kind of restrictions are we took
them out so basically i will show you
some demos real quick here so the idea
behind so this is all right so this is
basically video brush which is touch the
screen all right there we go yeah 20
lingers so basically this is a video
this is a video playing I can actually
now take all parts of it and just
basically kind of start playing around
with it if I want to I can scramble if I
can take each one of them by their own I
can actually solve it back end so the
idea this is kind of the type of
applications you can do with servo light
as well where you can take a media
content you can do whatever kind of
creative stuff you want it on top of it
as well also in terms of like Netflix
that's kind of one of our premier apps
does anyone everyone here have netflix
on the phone okay so i think we can skip
that demand yes everyone knows what
network however if the cool part about
it is we save netflix a lot of time
because they already have
it on the desktop so for them actually
pouring it over on the phone was really
easy in terms of the media stack and
getting started as well here where I'll
show is actually something we're
actually bring it in in in mango which
is basically sockets in rtm we didn't
have sockets so sockets is basically the
ability to you know if you wanted to
actually open a socket on a server you
can actually be able to communicate with
it so here's this is I call this chat
plus which is simply just a simple app I
can do this here and I can do let me see
it just depends on the network
connectivity so let's see if it actually
works real quick so here basically what
I'm doing is I'm drawing over here and
so actually drawing on the other side so
it's basically sending data through
multicast and through the network to to
the other device and here if I actually
draw on the other one I can do it as
well and I can draw both of them at the
same time here so that's basically one
of the cool apps that can be enabled on
on mango as well so and also there's a
lot of cool apps out there if I had time
to kind of go through them I would
actually do that but I think we'll just
actually go through in terms of what you
need to know in order to build those
kind of collapse so basically how many
people here are familiar with zamel okay
cool that's good so we'll skip this one
so basically here's just the idea behind
it is with serve a light the key
objected like if you used to like
programming with java script or C++ or C
sharp everything is in code in
silverlight you have a lot of kind of
the utilization of zamel where you can
actually write everything in kind of an
XML type format now the cool part about
it is it gives you the ability to
interface with designers much quicker
which I'll show you later on with blend
and how to actually reuse some of those
resources quickly so basically the idea
is server life is not just zamel you can
also write code behind it as well and
you can leverage both at the same time
so basically here i'll just show you a
quick demo of well how to actually
create a windows form project closely
and so basically this is just a simple
you kept Carter just getting second book
all right so uh this is just your read
everything so so this is visual studio
oh my god I can't see a thing all right
okay so the idea behind it is through
like in the browser ill like individual
study you can actually see what's going
on in here on sample I can create
whatever I want over here will click now
let me just see here a little just hide
that dude over here all right you know
what yes so the idea behind it is i can
create like whichever text box I can do
like I can do it through code and I can
do it as well through zamel as well so
for example here in my grid that can
okay
so basically here is just a design where
I can actually define word my zamel and
where's my phone and you can do that
through the UI real quickly where this
is this one here and I'll show you which
witch stackpanel you're like if I click
on the stack man it will tell me which
one is actually selected so this way you
can actually go ahead and program from
it over there I'll go into stackpanel i
bred so on and so forth later on as well
to give you some of the differences say
that's just basically a basic idea of
what salmon looks like i'll just it's
like oh so the idea is I can add a
button here and you know what we decide
so here you also have some of the other
cool tools where you can actually know
which position is it and you can
actually align it with other objects as
well also so basically this is what it
actually created over here or basically
you have the button selected so
basically you can create this thrus ammo
and basically you can go ahead from
there now in terms of the C code you can
actually double click and it will
actually go into the event go into the
c-sharp code where you can actually now
hook up all the events now the cool part
about this is in zamel you don't have to
actually go do the loaded you know in
C++ where you actually have to define
which events and hook them up to the
controls you can do that also through
zamel much cleaner like right over here
at the end do this yeah so you can
define what is the you know basically
the events on click and you also have
hook up to all the other events that you
want so for example here I can do load
it and you have like all the kind of the
intellisense help that you can actually
do and get you going real quickly so
that i can i'll pick that out of the way
here and get back to the presentation
all right
now the other cool part is actually you
can do a lot of things vector-based so
when you actually do things in c-sharp
and c++ if you wanted to do something
that's actually more native to the app
either a you can actually get an image
and you have to write a program to
actually manipulate it which kind of
becomes a little bit cumbersome here is
basically can actually take anything
from either Photoshop or kind of blend
where you can actually just basically
take that sample and just put it
immediately into the phone and you can
actually get get going there quickly let
me see you then so I'll just and also
the yeah and it actually shows you like
a lot of cool things you can manipulate
with blend and you can actually know
exactly what to do with it so I'll just
show you here kind of a quick demo of
blend real quickly now the cool part but
blend is actually creates the Microsoft
Project so you can actually use it in
collaboration with visual studio so okay
let me just close this so this is
basically blend and how it looks like
and I can just create a new project and
C minus one application and it actually
creates the same template that you had
on the phone as well where you can
actually now concentrate on the design
and concentrate on everything related to
it okay
so here I create the kind of a
Silverlight app and I can do a lot of
cool things with it as well like if this
is a list box that I actually now
designed with blend so if I want to
actually manipulate any objects just
create like change the colors or do any
editing on the text i can do that
quickly now the cool part about it is
let me just do the USA actually 11 here
I can actually see the saml for it as
well so the idea is I can create
something in in blend I can just
basically export it and just give it to
someone else who has actually using it
in visual studio as well and also you
can compare both of them at the same
time where you can see okay what are the
changes you didn't blend and how do they
reflect back in on on the phone is
themselves as well I can just go there
and just go back to the demo
now also the other part of it is with
controls you have a lot of controls in
visual studio so you have like in terms
of buttons you can actually do that in
example as I said and as well as you can
do media element you can do with the
listbox you can do all sorts of cool
stuff with with it as well also anything
that can be created in Zaman can be
created in encode as well I think yeah
we went through the stem over here real
quick now I'll just go over kind of the
differences between layout you know
canvas and stackpanel so for the idea is
you can actually lay out your objects
whether whichever way you want so with
canvas it's basically a fixed position
so you draw out an area you say okay
this is what I want at this pacific
specifics pixel width stackpanel you're
actually putting everything in either
one roll or 11 column so basically
everything is just stacked up together
and with grid is basically
self-explanatory you can just purchase
isn't possessing them like really kind
of in coordination with each other so
I'll just kind of show you where like a
really quick then we're here is there a
way to put this thing in full screen on
I think all right all right proud touch
it there we go
it was down the Elector 10 minutes ago
alright okay alright cool so the idea
behind it is I can just go over here
we're quick and I can just in this grid
so one of the actual examples of grits
is this in the template where you can
actually define what is the Royal
definition and what is kind of the row
height so the idea behind it is I have a
fixed amount of height but the rose you
can do as many as possible that you want
here basically i'll just do an example
of canvas so i can do canvas and
basically just throw a rectangle in it
can everyone see this or do you need me
to project higher or something like that
let's might okay so basically i can add
rectangle real quick and i can now the
cool part about this i can do like with
cat i can say okay relative to the
canvas where do i want it like to the
left to the right I can actually
position where were to start to kind of
a rectangle for it and as well as I can
say okay I wanted that 50 as well as I
can do canvas from the top to have it as
a 50 and as well as i can do i can
define the width for the rectangle and
that's the cool part about intellisense
that will actually just type everything
for you real quick and we'll know
exactly what you need to have also
basically yeah with let's say 100 and is
and I can see a fill sorry red like real
quick here and I can just close it down
and it'll actually just draw everything
here now any other rectangles will
actually be stacked right next to it
basically in the same position as well
so that is it gives you the ability
instead of actually trying to align your
rectangles yourself it'll just make it
actually a lot quicker for you as well
now also let's say I now I just want to
have a look another neck instead of this
I want to have or is it the like a
stackpanel where panel and I want to do
with orientation wise horizontal okay
you would live through this here is
better so no it's not better actually
okay
also see I can close this one down here
and I can now draw my rectangles in it
as well
and if you guys have any questions
please feel free to ask at any time this
is not like a presentation or anything
this is more of a inform what kind of
ask if you have any questions of what
about what I'm doing please go right
ahead and do it oh yes find this stuff
csharp goes well yes example yes so as I
said before it's basically if I go to
the you stay here I can okay let's part
I have to call this need first okay so
let me just do this here go view and I
can view code and basically what i can
do i can just do rectangle and basically
it's the same objects that you have in
an ins amal as well where you can do
wreck is equal to new rectangle and you
can do the whole definitions that you
did in zamel as well as here in code so
the idea is if you have event-based kind
of programming you want to modify it you
can do it also encode or if you have
already some libraries where it actually
defines the coordinates you can also use
them here as well any other questions
for the text
hell you're on the other is it too big
or is it too small for you oh yeah yeah
that's all right all right okay I can
zoom have a good time there we go
everyone happy all right so uh so
basically here I can just do it to fill
here real quick and do house blue and I
can do copy here real quick so as you
can see it'll actually stack them
correctly together like you don't have
to actually have the hassle of defining
word the coordinates where it actually
happens it'll just you can just copy
paste the kind of the controls real
quickly and we'll actually just create
them for you in that steam stackpanel
correctly you don't have to actually
manage the coordinates so on and so
forth also you can add the margin where
you can actually have the spacing
between them so you can do a margin
let's say 10 so you can actually now see
it's actually increases the size between
the both of them there as well so yeah
that's basically the presentation for
this is for stackpanel for grid you can
actually define basically the you know
which draw definition as well so I'll
just do a quick example here of it real
quick
so I can do
grid and
show grid lines I can say is equal to
true and no sorry
and here this is the important part is
grid definition oh sorry
we're actually i can define okay what is
really the height of each show that i
want so i can do you know items here
yeah i can do
as far as the room definition self
okay and then i can say broad definition
height is equal to 50 so basically you
can see here it actually created one of
the rows with that specific height and
the risk that actually is for other
roads as well so the idea behind it is
here you can define how do you want to
stack your grid and how do you want to
assign your columns as well so this way
you can control the positioning of all
your controls really quickly so I'll
just go really ahead quickly and all
right you guys had a question okay
that's giving all right cool that sounds
good and also you can do this with the
others this is the row column yep
and you can close it down and
and you also can control the grid column
as well here that's right
so here what I'm doing is actually
creating oh go ahead find these tools
and resources and like the stuff online
that we can work on this at home get
yourselves yeah I mean you can actually
go on to msdn and we're basically you
can go to the phone development page and
already we actually release the mango
mango tools or like for the next release
of Windows Phone 7 so you can actually
go ahead and pop them in and you can
actually start kind of coding and doing
a lot of cool stuff the best place to go
to jump off for everything phone related
as create msdn calm you refer to that as
a pup you can download the developer
tools there I recommend that if you're
interested in the competition this
summer download the mango tools it's a
public beta that came out last week and
there's links to sample app sample code
all the msdn docs are linked to from the
app hub site all right
oh yeah go ahead to be able views and
how do you get the stuff on here going
the first time oh okay so basically like
the tools that's actually available
right now you can use them for both like
Windows Phone 7 and as well as Windows
Phone mango now the emulator that comes
with it is actually the public released
for the mango build itself if you wanted
to actually put it on the phone
basically a you just have to register as
a developer or basically you get all the
kind of the tools in order to a unlock
your device and as well as to actually
launch your kind of test app into the
device that you have now you can buy any
like any any device and Windows Phone
device and you can update it to that and
you can actually launch your apps from
there now I think we still haven't kind
of released the actual on device we only
have the mango builds on emulators right
now later on we'll have them on actual
devices I want to talk about this later
but you actually have phones at the zap
fest events so I'm expecting that as we
go forward and people are having no apps
that we want to test on a phone I have
phones that you can use at these events
as part of the contest we're also going
to provide loaner phones for the summer
to each team that's going to build an
app so we will find a way to get a mango
capable device to anyone who's going to
participate in the competition but it
like the like Ivan said the emulators
great you can do pretty much everything
there as especially in the beginning
stages but obviously you're going to
want to have a phone too you'll finalize
your testing performance at all
bangles say that again which building
mangoes could
so so the question was which build a
mango is going to be on the phones the
bill that i have on the phones right now
is a half the friends and family bills
so that was 76 29 was the latest i think
there's a new friends and family film
coming out this week so i'll update the
phones to whatever that is but we will
keep those phones moving forward as
mango releases come out throughout the
summer alright cool so I'll just finish
off this real quick for the grid so that
is here what i did i simply kind of
define what is the grid like I created
the raw definitions here I created two
rows and I created two columns and what
i'm doing here is basically now any
shape that i have i'm defining in which
raw and which column does it actually go
to so here basically i'm simply saying
okay this this should be this should go
into kind of column 0 and as well as go
into the hole so into row 0 and I
actually kind of close now the rectangle
yeah I did the fill so you can see it's
actually now puts it in the the correct
kind of grid position that I want so
that's kind of the three different three
differences between layout like in
layouts you have canvas you have oh go
ahead you had a cushion all right well
how's the workload
you know it's right that was bigger
the way it actually does it is just it
depends on your definition if you do a
dot style actually just either expanded
or it'll actually just snip it for you
as well so it'll just actually handle it
for you so yeah with that I can just
move on to the next kind of demos now
with transforms you have a lot of cool
transfers you can do so on all the
shapes that we've actually drawn you can
actually do any anything that you want
that you can actually we have a lot of
kind of out-of-the-box solutions that
you can actually use for me in animating
or transforming any of the objects that
you have so so any of the controls yet
you have anything that's actually UI
element you can actually now transform
it or kind of do some cool stuff with it
so for example the video brush the first
example the video puzzler one is
basically we took some of the elements
and we just basically manipulated them
with those transforms that we have here
so so basically you have you either have
transforms or we have projections where
basically it applies 3d effects into 2d
elements so that's basically what we
have on the phone so basically the three
types of animation you have you have a
storyboard and end them you have
animation and you have the key frames so
the idea behind it is the storyboard you
define it's kind of like you're doing a
movie where you saying okay on this clip
I want it to be here on that clip I
wanted to do this and animation is
actually the mechanism of doing all that
and with the keyframes you can actually
specify the time frame that you want
with that I can just show you quickly
and blend here let me see you here
basically this is our like this is our
windows phone page so the idea is I just
want to draw the cool part about blend
is actually designed it's designed for
designers so you can do a whole kind of
cool stuff with it so for example here I
want to draw a rectangle and I'm just
basically drawing this here now I can
select it i can do a whole kind of crazy
stuff with it where I want to select
this I want to do the opacity I want to
change the pass it a little bit here
down there and I want to do some cool
stuff with it like a gradient type where
I can actually select it over here and
select this color and select it
something else and I can select this
color as this here yeah and how is that
ok
so this is a gradient brush here it
basically selects what are the colors on
so here you can actually select ok this
I don't want it to be white I want it to
be something like green and the black
here I want it to be this color over
here sorry so you can do all kind of
cool stuff with it basically all those
elements actually coincide well with
what you ever you have in the actual
visual studio project so basically all
the kind of terminology are actually
almost the same so if you're actually a
design you're working with the
developers you can actually collaborate
much easier go ahead in your run that
you have already implemented api's for
things like face recognition or voice to
text or voice recognition and things
like that it's made using mobile
applications no so currently we don't
actually have those implemented as you
know by default but there's like a lot
of code out there in the developer
community that's actually make those
very easy to do people also use services
yes because some of the things that you
just mentioned like speech to face there
is a surface part of co by which you can
actually use and send it off to the
flower get it done and then come back
but doesn't have the sub latency program
is going to it does have of course
because it's the next football but the
good thing is you get to those thing
alright thanks so here basically what i
want to do is I want to do some cool
animation on this so what I'll do I'll
just go to the saml page here so that
the off sorry another one so here you
can see you have all the saml code and
what it did for you it actually just
saved you a whole bunch of time on kind
of defining what's the gradient will do
the same trick we did before we
minimized we yep so you can see here
basically it actually drew up all the
sama for you so you don't actually need
to actually worry about okay what's the
color for this what's the color for that
you can actually just use blend it'll
actually just make it easier for you and
the cool part is this project can
actually be opened in visual studio so
for example i can say edit here sorry i
can say here and like i can select the
actual pocket ok and the mouse is a
little so you can actually also view the
sama for it so moving on i'll just show
you kind of how to do animation so here
what you have to do is just basically
create a unused and used to ok new story
board so we'll just do a demo here so
here what you have on the left pane is
actually the timelines that you want so
now we're actually starting recording so
what i can do i can just select this
move it over here oh sorry i can say
over here i can say at this time frame I
want it to be over here and as well as I
can do some all right basically we have
a lot of cool stuff in terms of the
easing function where I can actually now
apply other transforms to it as well so
for now I actually moved it over here
and then I want to do something at this
time where I want to rotate it a little
bit so this is the projection I'm
actually rotate taking it like towards
us and I want to do
this as well here we're actually rotated
this way and then at this time frame I
want to move it over here basically so
that is now I can do a play it'll
actually do all this for you as well so
that is I will create all this
storyboard for you real quickly you
don't actually have to write all this
code you don't have to worry about okay
if this at this projection I have to
apply this function to it it's just you
can just apply it here real quickly you
can get going easily and as I said
before and also if you want to stop you
can just stop kind of be the launching
of it as well also here or f11 and also
you have so basically all this it
actually created all this kind of
storyboard ins ammo for you so you can
actually use it as well as it created
all these transformations that you had
which is basically as I said before you
can apply transforms into any object
that you have here we actually applied
it to the rectangle and also the cool
part about blend is you can actually
launch it in the emulator as well so
it's basically as if it's actually a
development studio still like two or
four years work so i can now launch it
in the emulator i can see how it
actually looks now i think here the
problem is simply what will happen is it
won't move it will actually be static
now the reason is because we actually
just created the storyboard we didn't
hook up the events for it now there's
two school of thoughts one is to
actually leave it to the developer to
hook up all the events and just
basically have the designer do kind of
what's really the behavior the other one
is actually just have the the designer
actually also defined what's the
behavior if it's actually something
really quick and in blend you can
actually do that really quickly so here
you can actually this emulator you can
run it from visual studio as well as
blend so the idea is you don't have
reduced functionalities as well so
basically this is the app I can actually
keep it in there and I can actually just
run again for it so what's good so here
the idea is I can now define a new
behavior where I can say you can go to
in the left side you can select all
these controls
one of them you can you have a lot of
things out of the box so for us what we
want is actually something something
called behaviors so the idea is here you
can actually control a lot of the events
in your program from you can actually
hook them up from visuals from blend as
well so that is here I want to control
the storyboard one does it happen that's
what I want to do and to what do I want
to apply it so instead of actually
writing it cone code I can actually do
it from the UI here real quick yeah so
here I actually select which element
that I want to actually apply to I say
this this one over here okay yeah i can
say on this dude and oh it's create both
same time yes here are basically I say
okay on which do I want to actually
apply to which we said the rectangle and
basically what's the event and let's say
here just loaded like once its loads I
wanted to apply this animation so once
we go back into kind of the emulator
forgot to do one thing here
lives here
yeah well bubs why you sorry yeah yep
so yeah so basically you can actually do
it really quickly really easily so yeah
that's basically what they're in
transforms you can do a lot of cool
stuff with it a lot of cool animations
and I'm like the technical guy I don't
know like a lot of cool stuff to do but
probably all of you guys have a lot of
cool ideas to actually implement on the
phone and we're looking forward to it so
that's that then we here and we'll now
the other cool part about server light
is actually you can apply a consistent
format to everything so the idea behind
it is you can actually in your resources
you can define what's really the style
that you want to apply so here real
quickly I can all right so the idea
behind it is here is simply in this
example here what I'm doing is just
saying what's the target type like any
text box that I want I want it to have
these set of properties so here
basically what I'm saying you always
have the setter which says okay I want
the font size to be this and I want the
property to be a certain point now this
is very basic now you can actually go
crazy in terms of the style and this is
actually how we implemented it on the
phone as well we're basically we applied
the style specific for the phone which
matches the Metro design which basically
makes it more consistent with the shell
you I itself so basically any app that
you right out of the box it actually
looks like as if it's a first part yeah
it's not something like a third party
developer have written it so with that I
can just go quickly into the demo so so
here I created an already done project
I'm just do this
so musically this is the this is Eddie
projects that you have let me just hide
this here real quick so here what we
have is just simply a project of screwed
10 okay
so here basically what we have i created
an app that has three types of buttons
so basically here in my main page that's
a mo i have the default button which is
simply it's kinda tricky yeah you want
no this happened yeah they just soon
dude
so the idea behind it here is I have
three types of button this one the first
one is just simply I did buttons mo with
so on and so forth and basically I
didn't set it up to any style the second
1i basically applied like a really quick
style to it which is basically custom
button if you get actually go to this
style over here basically what I did is
I just say ok the control template which
is basically saying okay what do I want
to do with the actual UI and I said
basically set to wet through it to the
height of the template itself so this
way it automatically calculates it for
you so basically if you expand it you
you know we you collapse it you can
actually maintain kind of the same
height and width here basically I just
as we did like in in blend i defined
kind of what's the gradient color and
where does it stop or does it end so
basically those are kind of the radial
radial gradient brush which basically
defines okay you can do like the colors
here and the other colors over on the
other side so basically this is the
upset and what is really the colors on
both end of the spectrum and basically
yeah I defined this as kind of the i
define my I button to be an ellipse and
it defined what's that ellipse is
actually filled with here the content
presenter is basically simply whatever
is the content of the button so when you
go actually two main page the exam oh
and you see this content over here it's
basically this one over here it's like
how do you want to present this content
of the button and that's basically what
we did over here real quick now of
course i have another style here for
text so it's not only just for buttons
you can also all do it for all types of
controls so here i have one for text i
can just show you real quick how does it
make a difference so here this is called
subheading text so basically we have
this keep an eye on this text over here
all i'm going to do is just simply
instead of actually using the default
phone templates a default folan styles
i'll just change it to something else so
i'll just go with
heading what was it called sub sub
heading text thanks
so basically it's kind of flipped it
over like real quickly for you so the
idea is if you have like multiple text
you want them to have the same style you
can do that and they the way you do it
is you actually have something an apt
sam'l which basically holds your
resources so the idea behind it is in
your application resources you can set
the common things for you know for all
the pages in your app to actually use
yeah that's basically one of them here
for now this is actually very
complicated like a you know really cool
but kind of somewhat kind of involved
template so the idea behind this one
here I'll just show you kind of snippets
of it is basically we're defining how it
looks like now we're also defining the
transition like if you click it what
will happen in the background what color
does it give so the idea is you're
giving some transitions do with it well
so the way you control that is actually
by visual state manager so the idea
behind it is you can you can create the
template as we did before then you can
actually define your visual state
manager which will kind of give you all
the storyboards on top of it where you
can define how does it behave at certain
points so I'll just go over to prove
quickly here what we're doing here is
just simply creating the storyboards
that we want we want and giving them
names that coordinate with the events
like when I press I say visual state
press and it will actually do this
animation for me and the same thing with
you know the you know if it's actually
disabled as well like if it's disabled
it will actually be a different color so
yeah with that I can just show you like
a real quickly how does it look like in
enzyme and on the emulator here let me
just closes do it first
anyone has any questions until this
thing comes up
Oh specialized world yes yes you can and
actually there's a lot of cool tools
there as well where you can actually
like add a new style you can do it and
you can actually export it as well or
you can actually just open it up in
visual studio and this tile will be
there as well so the idea is here this
is the default button which was from
phone page this one here we didn't
define the kind of depressed events so
it's just simply kind of the shape of it
this one here as you can see we're
actually managing the visual state
forest where we're actually saying okay
change the color for it once I pressed
on it so here it gives you an idea what
styles you can do like if you want to
look at a custom control or anything
that you want it you can actually do
very easily as well with the server
light we can just hear all right now the
other cool cool part is 0 we have a
question yes about the events in the
States yes are they based on like the
states from a mouse they live in
silverlight cuz i felt like focus thing
firstly you left but down her up how
does that go all right how did that sync
up with the phone now it syncs up so the
way you actually like in terms of like
all the events that you have in
civilized you can actually hook them up
through the visual state control so
that's kind of the way you would you
would do them so your question is how
easy it is or how what's the limitation
what's it to the phone basically
whatever you want it to be so basically
you give each state like a name and you
basically enable it whenever you hook it
up to the events that's actually
available on the phone so whatever
actually events available on the phone
you can actually hook them up to it so
that's kind of the way you do it please
good idea pony and they I don't know
yeah okay you mean in terms of like a
tonic you mean in terms of like it does
it only happen like on that object or
that's a guy or they can be 30 then
that's up oh you mean okay okay um they
could I mean they do like four controls
it won't happen that often but it should
be fine like it is kind of atomic but
it's basically up to you basically to
handle it okay no it's actually
guaranteed like each for each event each
event that you actually hook up with
it'll actually fire the correct event
for you okay uh should we give folks
five minutes all right okay Lisa all
right okay so the next item we're
actually going to talk about is just
simply like if you have a listbox how do
most people here actually control what's
in the list box and you select something
out if you know how does it go away like
how do you actually manage the data that
you have in your app just as a general
question like how do you how do you guys
usually do it data but yeah okay good
point yeah so basically here what we
have is just a simple way of actually
managing how do you actually connect the
data with the controls that you have so
here what we have is actually property
binding as well as list binding as well
so that is let's say you have a list box
you can just control one item of it
where you can just control the you know
observablecollection or any kind of list
that you have and it'll actually
automatically update your list box
automatically so this way you don't
actually need to manage basically okay
selected make sure you take it out and
you have to manage like multiple data at
the same time you can just control from
one endpoint so basically there's a
couple of ways of overdoing it you can
actually do within a two-way connection
or in just one way so either you can
have the source control what's over
there or you can have them both
controlling each other as well so with
that I can just actually show you a
quick demo here I love this mouse all
right
so basically this is a solution that we
have done so basically what I'm doing is
simply I have a list of images that I
basically have automatically kind of pre
populated and all I'm doing is just
basically putting them in a listbox so
what I'll show you now is just actually
just simple binding and what does it
mean and like loose binding how do you
actually do it as well as some advanced
scenarios where you can actually
implement your own kind of collections
so it's not just simply text you can
actually add anything you want in a list
box where you can add images plus text
the list goes on and on so with that I
can just show you some code like real
quick on the simple one all right
this is the simple one is just simply
what I'm going to do is just take to
list box and just let one control the
other what's actually going over there
so I'll just add
this text plot this text box as well as
this text block over here so that is you
can think of it as your you want to
implement like a typing kind of scenario
as well alright so here we have these
two text blocks and what I'm going to do
is just rename them real quick I'll just
say this is input and this is output and
what I'll do is just basically add like
a data to data binding to it so what
I'll do is simply here to say
I'll say what's the text in it I'll just
say sorry
I want to bind it to something and I say
I want to bind the text so it's kind of
like okay what do you want to bind so
here's this is the target property that
you want to actually bind and you can
also add like with which kind of control
that you want to bind it to so the idea
behind it is here let's say you have
multiple controls instead of actually
knowing which property you want you can
just actually hook that control with the
other one very quickly and very easily
so here basically I can just say element
all right
turn
excuse me is that like Adele we can get
you soon as you would say like patty
please text which is a property name and
then Delmon
the other object or control yes exactly
exactly that's how it's going to be
equal i think i have another text that's
why yeah this one yeah
here I can give it an element name and I
can say input
and looks bad boy here
we're good
yeah I got I got a guy hi there
so the idea behind it is here we can
actually run this real quick
so here I can control it you can saying
this and you can see it actually
automatically binds it to the other text
and so basically you don't actually need
to add events and okay this is equal to
that here is actually handled for you
pretty good pretty quickly so that's
kind of like some of the simple kind of
data binding that you can do quickly on
the phone now for listbox is kind of the
same thing as well so I'll just
basically stopped bugging the session
here
so here we can actually go to the list
then what kind of example where I can
create like a cook list box so what I'll
do is just simply drag and drop like a
real quick list box here and what I'll
do is just basically in my in Miami will
just create a real quick in my code i'll
just create like a quick string over
here of of stuff of what what it is so
i'll just do a string of stuff over
there legacy here yeah also if you want
I can show you kind of the way you can
do two-way binding as well where you
could have two of them actually control
each other so if you want we can go
ahead and do that here I'll just
continue this on real quick so basically
here I can do aircraft and in my thing
here I can do aircraft
that's what I can do it this way
p15
so what I'll do here is just simply say
here answer basically buying this to the
list that i actually created this box
dot one dot itemssource is basically
just equal to aircraft
so the idea behind it here is I don't
need to actually pass or it I think it's
better this way
yeah there we go so basically what I'm
doing is just basically creating a list
box and just immediately giving the
source to any kind of type of collection
that I have so the idea behind it is you
don't need to worry about the types you
don't have to worry about okay if this
type actually matches that one you can
just immediately any type of collection
you can actually just set your controls
to that item and we'll actually can
control the the content of the listbox
from this collection over here that you
have and that's basically it for this
app over here so if I go to
this binding is actually automatically
kind of just basically points it out and
you can actually edit them the way you
want each Rosa custom you
that's the next one we're actually
looking at so this one here is now the
advanced one or the one that we're
actually taking a look at basically this
is the advanced view basically what i
have is in my in my zamel alright this
is kind of the way you would control it
so a you would actually just have to in
your list box you will create a data
template with item templates as well so
here you actually define how does it
actually how does the data look like so
what we did here we actually define the
item template and we defined like a data
template type and we basically said like
okay the data should look like in a
stackpanel where you have as we said
stackpanel stacks them together at the
same time and you don't have to worry
about a thing and here basically what
you're saying is I want it both I have a
have the source as a an image and as
well as a text box which is basically
the most common kind of scenario that
you will have here basically we said
okay bind this to like thumbnail and
name now those actually come from the
specific class that we actually created
so the way you would do it is simply we
create an aircraft class which simply is
just a string and like the source to the
source to the actual images that you
want to actually set so all we did is
just basically find those and what we
did is basically we made it inherit I
notification property changed so with
this what it does is just simply says
okay I want this to be hooked up with
the notification events so this way
whenever it actually changes it actually
raises up an event so you basically go
through your kind of normal kind of
methods as well as constructors here
this is the important part where you can
actually say in the set you can actually
fire up the event saying okay a property
has changed so this way if you have a
collection of this class
s and some you know it actually changed
you can actually now fire up the event
and you can actually handle it the
listbox will actually handle it for you
and the same thing with the thumbnail as
well where if that happened you can
actually raise it up and you can
actually raise this events over here
with this thumbnail and that's how you
got the data binding one where a name
and thumbnail basically they come from
those over here so back to back back to
our zamel over here so basically that's
it we just defined kind of the data
template and how does it look like and
now the other item we need to hook up is
just simply the the button where if I
click delete it actually takes it out so
going to the code for that one let me
just see here so here what I'm doing
simply is just creating a list of type
class and that's how you have to do it
so any any items that you wanted to
actually be able to data bind it has to
be a type from the generic class so it's
either can be a list an array or any
kind of generate a genetic collection
that you want here are basic I'm just
statically creating them one by one and
I'm just basically data binding the list
box that I have into this
observablecollection that I just created
so it's just simply I have a collection
I just set it up there and that's it now
here in the deleted button all I'm doing
is just simply deleting it from the
actual collection that we created so
we're not actually doing we're not
managing the actual list box we're
managing the observablecollection for it
and that's how I was actually being
controlled and with that that's
basically how you can actually do data
binding with over the server lights any
questions in regards to this ok cool you
can actually just move along I think
we're at right time here and basically
the idea behind just kind of to wrap up
things the idea behind it is just make
sure you can if you have code on the
desktop especially with server light
make sure you can actually reuse it
special also if you have custom controls
you can actually put them in very easily
to to the phone
also in terms of if you have like so you
basically just reuse as much as you I
and as much as code that you want from
the desktop into the end to the phone as
well and with that basically just the
call of action is just download the
tools you know start building like
really cool apps you guys are young you
guys have a lot of cool ideas and yeah
if you have any questions please let us
know and we can help you out cool any
questions yes level yeah any questions
that it's okay up please excellent
alright cool doesn't work Oh next
I see what you mean okay the question
basically the question is can we post
them instead of just in a domain kind of
net like instead of just posting it
eternally can we actually also post it
externally as well where folks actually
from home can actually download them I
can yeah I can post those out those
shouldn't be so bad yep cool all right
cool